一定要做可以接的事
千万千万不要等你发现的时候
问题已经完了
我就问大家一个问题
假设我说假设
你被公司才完了
然后你后面讲面臨的什么
我不是被言所听了
就今天我遇到一个多年到老朋友
就是一家公司的高官
因为公司的经营出了一些问题
然后他现在年龄也带了
然后突然发现走红布的时候
找不到了
找不到合作公路
他的心随特别特别的地
然后
正好今天晚上我们内部视频会以
正好有老化界
在一个行业工作十多年
然后发现不但
找不到更合适的工作
生活加新吗
找得更好的去
而且一旦公司拾退了
发现马上就面对生活问题
还有我们老化学生们就做
传统的建筑行业的
在行业所的飞动的时候有足结果
就是这个行业突然目楼了
所以
这就是一个问题
就是我想跟大家分享的
就一定要做可以
期待的事
我们工作两种一种叫楼是一样做业
什么意思呢就是
今天做今天做完了以后这个事就过去了
还有一种是期待的
可以不断不断的持续的
我们很多人会陷入成人陷阱
老鼠长陷阱
然后销生课的陷阱
然后同场陷阱你们还要带头到陷阱
啥意思呢
就是我默认的情况下
我们的生活方式是什么样的就是从小
好学习考上一个学校
然后毕业早份是好工作
然后
买个房子买个车去期生死
然后不断的身罩提升我们的能力
对吧
有时候回来类的时候的话
可以
可以看看视频
大家游戏啊对不对
但是我就问对我们每个问题
就订阴所在那个行业有机内嘛
或者你自己有机内嘛
万一经济下行
万一你被慈退了
万一你年龄大了
对吧
这个会出现什么问题呢
就我们很远遇到这个问题但是马上有没有另外两个问题
什么问题呢
第一个就是我们我接触不到新的思维
很能说后来往是评论不施的
不是的
就是我们说叫叫
就是信息牢龙啊
就你身边的人呢
包括你的每天推送的信息啊
都是你这个领域的
我不是在被人送听
然后很多时候呢也预止到这个问题的但是
但是不知道怎么出去
就洗得性无助不知道到底该怎么做
所以我给大家建议就是从现在开始
一定要做
累级性的工作
你千万不要每天就是每天
跑滑滑还起座的行业做很长的一段时间了
对吧但是难免出现经历下行吗公司啊不行啊
对吧这个领域不行啊对吧这样的一个问题
那么该怎么做呢
首先我之前给大家分享过一个方法
这个方法是什么呢就是每天学点什么
就很难觉得这是很小的样子是不是的
不是这是一套很有用的系统啊
首先第一个事情
就是每天学点什么学什么
我今天做了什么事
就遇到什么问题了
我是怎么解决的
注意后面这句话
是否还可以用在别的场景
如果没有
不可以用到别的场景的
那么很可能你做的这个事情
这个领域这个行业但出现下行的时候这个就不靠负用了
这是第一件事情
第二件事总结出来
如果可以用到别的行业那么他可以几个什么问题
解决发案及方法是什么
有没有更通的绝方法
是否可以把它输立成一个可以几个东西
有说是个魔法呢是个流程啊
是一天文章啊
对吧
或者是一个产品啊一个场景啊
对对
第三步把它发布出去
发布出去怎么就性命表面气
哪怕能力能力
我们差不多但是让看到的更多的人那么我的性命表面机就更多
这本身就是一个几个的过程同时的话呢
它是不断的电力建立你
学习能力思考能力和这个对外输出能力
这是一个基本盘同时不断的进行机的
所以个技术三多啊
对于他摆脱一来
第二个部分
行程系统
那些些点什么
让他可以几个第三
起累
资产